c'est bien pour ce mot
e
attention j'ai choisi le rêve j'ai
choisi de rêver de rêver devient tunisie
que j'aime d'une tunisie plurielle
note 6 culturel multiethnique du tunisie
que je n'ai pas vu du midi où nous avons
vécu un petit peu caché je suis désolé
j'ai pas une voix qui porte
j'ai commencé à crier d'accord donc pour
revenir au rêve
je suis je suis venu au rêve
après une réflexion quand le mur du
silence est tombé que je ne voyais pas
mes congénères et mes compatriotes dans
la rue je me suis dit il n'ya pas mieux
que de les faire rêver rêver d'une
frénésie meilleur les rassembler autour
d'un rêve mais pas seulement eux
rassemblés tous les tunisiens qui
partagent vos idéaux ils sont sains
ceux de l'égalité de la liberté et d'une
certaine fraternité
pourquoi je dis certaine fraternité
parce que nous avons oublié nos origines
à petit feu il ya eu l'oubli de cette
tunisie africaine c'est cet oubli là que
je voudrais reconstruire dans la mémoire
des gens dans la mémoire des jeunes et
de ceux qui vont venir
comment la reconstruire face à la lgv
prix et j'ai choisi la carte de la
fraternité façon revendications
j'ai choisi d'inscrire quelque chose qui
n'a pas été inscrite malheureusement
dans notre constitution
c'est les différences
on n'aime pas les différences mode pas
les chaises livre est loin pas les gens
différents
c'est ce questionnement qui a fait que
même 10 et nées même tiéné justement de
ce rêve où toutes les différences pour
toutes les couleurs se fondre et pour
n'en former qu'une celle de l'amitié de
la citoyenneté aussi donc aujourd'hui
brièvement je vous parle de solaire
parce qu'il me tient à coeur parce que
je suis certaine que si je rêve seul ce
n'est qu'un rêve mais si nous rêvons
ensemble un jour ça deviendra une
réalité
j'aimerais que la mémoire collective
oublie certaines choses voir les efface
les mots qui font mal les choses d'une
rose d'un passé qui ne nous ressemble
pas aujourd'hui ne ressemble pas à la
tunisie que nous aimons c'est pourquoi
aussi je suis en train de faire le tour
de la tunisie de bonnes âmes
ah bon je travaille pour ça une petite
voix parmi tant d'autres mais
l'essentiel est de ne pas garder le
silence
l'essentiel est de ne pas oublier et
l'essentiel est de faire passer un
message ce message que je voudrais pas
c'est la diversité n'est pas une si
mauvaise chose
la diversité est notre richesse il faut
le savoir
nous n'avons pas de très grande richesse
pétrolière tout se passe pour nous dans
la matière grise une zone là d'une zone
à cette matière grise pour faire des
choses extraordinaires qui n'ont aucun
rapport avec l'argent mais qui vous nous
rapporter beaucoup
notre pays dit on à 3000 ans d'âge non
un peu plus pour nous a parlé d'alain on
nous a parlé de toutes ces femmes qui
ont fait la tunisie mais la tunisie est
beaucoup plus vieille que ça on dit la
tunisie est une terre d'accueil
est ce que vous pensez vraiment moi je
ne le pense pas quand je suis dans la
rue quand j'entends dans un supermarché
et sub saharienne où un succès arrière
se faire traiter de tous les maux quand
je la vois pleurer
en sortant du travail après 12 13 voire
15 heures des shows courbet et la mesure
on ne l'a pas brillé elle ne semble pas
ça le clusif elle ressemble à beaucoup
d'autres choses
une terre de passage oui une terre
d'accueil
certainement mais pas lutter de l je ne
parle je n'ai pas l'air parce que elle
est porteuse c'est un oiseau qui est
porteur d'une très mauvaise augure
il est porteur de la désunion le fameux
et dans mon rêve justement c'est une
tunisie une pluriel donc c'est pour ça
que je vous invite
je vis de tous ceux qui peuvent
l'écouter
si ma voix porte à changer de modèle à
ce modèle de vie allait changer
comment tout simplement en changeant un
petit peu ce qui à petit par coûter nous
nous n'avons pas besoin de beaucoup
si chaque personne si chacune d'entre
nous ne connaît que 100 personnes de
faire passer ce message
d'ici quelques années il fera le tour de
la tunisie et peut être même qu'il
traversera l'autre côté de la
méditerranée nous sommes maghrébin dit
on nous sommes north africa oui je
l'accord
mais aussi nous sommes profondément
intrigant j'aimerais un jour voir dans
les librairies les livres et les
recueils de léopold sédar senghor il est
bon de connaître ce qui s'est passé de
l'autre côté du continent
j'aimerais un jour rencontré un enfant
qui puisse me citer les cinquante trois
étapes restant de l'afrique
il n'y a pas que la tunisie le maroc
l'algérie la libye la maintenant et axa
il serait intéressant un jour de le
connaître de nous reconnaître de nous
accepter en tant qu'africains nous
sommes très fiers de dire que notre pays
a été le premier à bollène esclavage
nous sommes très fiers de dire que la
tunisie a donné son nom à tout un
continent
continuons à être fiers de ce pays
en envisageant un projet un projet
commun à nous tous on appellerait tous
ensemble vivre ensemble le rêve
peut-être je rêve qu'un jour au milieu
de tous ces ministères qu'il y ait le
ministère de la diversité la diversité
pourrait inclure tous les tunisiens et
même les noms tunisien qui par amour par
dévouement par quelques bribes de
l'histoire ont choisi de vivre chez et
dont les aidons justement à se vivre
simple qui pourra nous emmener moins on
pourra réussir à gagner toutes les
guerres ont vivent ensemble en
ressentant l'autre on et ont de
l'empathie pour l'autre très important
d'en pâtir encore rêve je rêve un jour
qu'il y ait un cours aux enfants très
jeunes qui vont à l'école leur apprendre
l'empathie pourquoi l'empathie pour moi
c'est le chemin le plus court pour un
enfant pour apprendre à vivre avec
l'autre l'autre quelle que soit notre
j'aimerais ne plus entendre quand je
passe dans la rue et qu'un enfant porte
un petit appareil derrière l'oreille il
est maintenant temps dans ce même
joyal mais ce marché j'aimerais qu'un
enfant très petit cours pour aider
quelqu'un qui a indiqué mme blanche qui
tâtonne justement parce qu'il est tout
simplement mal voyants il ne peut pas
voir dans de valeur tant de choses qu'on
pourrait construire sont les politiciens
on n'a pas besoin d'argent pour
construire tout ça on a besoin
simplement du rang de science
j'espère justement un jour voir cette
conscience révélé j'ai tous les
tunisiens
chez vous notamment qui êtes jeunes vous
multipliez les événements multiplier les
rencontres
leak au coeur de ces rencontres ne
l'oublié pas la diversité est quelque
chose de très important
finalement oui je suis différente mais
je suis une femme fait de toutes les
femmes qui vaut n'importe quel fond et
qui les vaut tout aussi pour terminer je
ne veux plus entendre ces vieux adages
le il me freine nos bêtes il
il ne freine un petit peu dans mon élan
j'ai fait dernièrement dans le sud est
si je vous disais un adage on dit
généralement où il fallait rafa est la
réponse pour certains déclara le ce que
j'entends dans le sud ce que j'ai
entendu la semaine dernière ma fille
j'ai de faire la claque à face à maui
l'ossif netla kenza cac
je ne veux plus rentrer ça je ne veux
plus vivre ça dans le regard des autres
je ne veux plus que ce regard de mépris
je ne veux plus du déni je veux oublier
tout ça je veux que les petits enfants
vivent dans la paix vivre leur
tunisianité s'ils ont choisi leur
africanité vie
tout simplement on a besoin de vivre
sans être cachés sans être méprisé ça
c'est le vivre ensemble
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]